Salut Romain ! Oh dis-donc t'as des petits yeux toi ?
Romain : Ah Non non non !
Crache dans le lavabo là, pour voir
(Bruit de toux)
C'est bien ce que je pensais
*musique d'intro*
Fumer du cannabis c'est interdit sauf si on est malade
Enfin dans certain pays ...
Ça peut paraitre difficile à comprendre, Ça peut même sembler un peut injuste
Mais le fait est que le cannabis, Comme les médicaments,
Il a ses indications, c'est à dire les cas dans lesquels on peut en donner
Mais aussi ces contre-indications, c'est à dire les cas dans lesquels il est déconseillé
Et même des effets indésirables, mais là je crois qu'on se comprend ...
Le principe actif, c'est à dire ce qui provoque les effets qu'on connait du cannabis
C'est le tétrahydrocannabinol
Mais on va l'appeller le THC si vous voulez bien
Même si vous voulez pas d'ailleurs ... T  H  C ... Tu vas faire quoi ?
*musique de thug life*
Le THC donc c'est une substance de la famille de cannabinoïdes
Et des cannabinoïdes on en trouve pas que dans les clips de Snoop Dogs ou dans les Insta' de Rihanna
Notre corps en sécrète aussi
On appelle ça les cannabinoïdes endogènes ou endocannabinoïdes
Et le plus connu c'est l'anandamide
Anandamide ça vient du  sanskrit "Ananda" ... Non ... "aNNanda"
Qui veut dire bonheur suprême, Béatitude, Felicité
Et de "Amide" qui n'est pas un prénom mais qui est un composé chimique organique
Sa découverte est assez récente : 1992
Et son rôle est encore mal connu mais ce serait un neurotransmetteur
Ou plutôt un neuromodulateur,  c'est à dire, une substance
qui modifie la façon dont les cellulles nerveuses communiquent entre elles
Les endocannabinoïdes agissent en se fixant sur des récepteurs cannabinoïdes présent
Sur certains de nos neurones
Quand quelqu'un consomme du cannabis sous n'importe quelle forme
Le THC vient se fixer sur ces récepteurs et comme son taux
est beaucoup plus élevé que celui des endocannabinoïdes
Il vient perturber les fonctions concernées
Les endocannabinoïdes, on sait pas encore précisemment à quoi ils servent
mais on sait que les recepteurs se trouvent principalement dans le cerveaux et le système nerveux central
Et notament au niveau du système limbique
Responsable de la régulation des émotions
Du thalamus qui s'occupent des perceptions sensoriels
Ce qui explique parfois certaines modifications de la vue ou l'audition
Du cervelet, chargé de la motricité, c'est la raison pour laquelle
le cannabis peur ralentir les mouvements et donner quelque problème de coordinations si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
Mais aussi du Cortex et de l'Hippocampe
Qui sont sièges de la mémoire mais ça ...
On va en parler plus tard
Le endocannabinoïdes on aussi un rôle
dans la libération de la dopamine qui joue, elle, un rôle clé dans le plaisir
C'est ce qui explique cet état d'euphorie que vous ne connaissez pas
parce que vous ne fumez pas de cannabis
Bien sur
Pour finir sachez qu'on trouve aussi des recepteurs cannabinoïdes
Dans l'utérus, les testicules, l'intestin, la vessie, la rétine
mais qui sont moins actifs que ceux du cerveaux
et que il y en a aussi au niveau du système immunitaire
Je vous vois venir, vous allez me dire : "Oui, c'est bien mignon tous ces salamalecs"
Mais nous ce qu'on veut savoir c'est pourquoi ça donne les yeux rouges comme ça"
Romain : Bah oui voilà ! C'est ça qu'on veut savoir !
Et pas toutes tes salamalecs
Oui bon bah 2 secondes j'arrive
Le THC a un effet vasodilatateur, ce qui fait qu'il dilate un certains nombres de vaisseaux sanguins
et notamment dans les yeux, au niveau des conjonctives
et c'est ce qui donne cette couleurs rouge
Cet effet vasodilatateurs il a aussi une autre consequence
celle de provoquer des chutes de tension lorsqu'on se lève un peu trop vite
et oui parce que dans un gros tuyau, y'a toujours moins de préssion que dans un petit tuyau
Mais ça Romain, tu peux pas le savoir
Ah et la vous allez me demander : "Oh et la bouche sèche alors ? Pourquoi ça donne la bouche sèche ?"
Romain : Bah ouais Julien pourquoi ça donne la bouche sèche comme ça ?
On peut se tutoyer ?
Si le cannabis donne la bouche sèche c'est parce que l'anandamide
joue un rôle dans la régulation de l'appétit, du coup y'a des recepteurs dans
les glandes salivaires
et il peut avoir pour fonction de ralentir la productions de salive
Voire de la stopper quand les récepteurs sont saturés de THC
D'ailleurs avant que Romain me pose la question, la raison pour laquelle le cannabis ça donne
si faim, ça à longtemps été pas trés clair
mais il y a une équipe de chercheurs de Yale qui pense avoir trouvé une explication
Le cannabis perturberait un neurone habituellement  chargé de transmettre les informations
sur la satiété, c'est à dire l'informations selon laquelle le corps a eu sa dose
et que c'est plus la peine de manger
A la place le neurone perturbé se mettrait à transmettre le signal de la faim
c'est à dire le message exactement inverse
N'importe quoi
(téléphone qui sonne) (Musique douce)
SOS dépression : Jean-Michel Neurone à votre écoute ... Oui ..
Ooh, ah ouais ! Hola
Ah oui c'est moche, Oh lala oui
Mais non mais écoutez, il faut se rendre à l'évidence,
Ça va jamais s'arranger votre histoire, mais non mais c'est foutu
mon vieux, laissez tout tomber
Allo, Allo, Bon ...
Dis-donc Thérèse c'est quoi votre marque de cigarettes là
Ça m'a tout perturbé
J'aime bien
Sauf qu'en locurence transmettre le mauvais message ça peut être très positif
C'est même l'une des indications qu'on appelle le cannabis thérapeutiques ou le cannabis médicale
Mais ça on en parlera dans une prohaine video parce que là ça fait déjà un moment que je parle
et que vous avez autre chose à faire, Alors à très très bientôt
*musique de fin*